let's think about what functions really
do and then we'll think about the idea
of an inverse of a function so let's
start with a pretty straightforward
function let's say i have f of x is
equal to
2 x plus 4. and so if i take f of 2
f of two is going to be equal to two
times two
plus four which is four plus four which
is eight i could take f of three
f of three which is two times 3
plus 4 which is equal to
right 6 plus 4. so let's think about it
in a little bit more of an abstract
sense so there's a set of things that i
can input into this function you might
already be familiar with that notion
it's the domain
the set of all the things that i can
input into that function that is the
domain
that is the domain and in that domain 2
is sitting there 2 is there you have 3
over there pretty much you could input
any real number into this function so
this is going to be all reals but we're
making it a nice contained set here just
to help you visualize it now when you
apply the function let's think about
what it means to take f of two we're get
we're inputting a number two and then
the function is outputting the number
eight it is mapping us from two to eight
so let's make another set here of all of
the possible values that my function can
take on
all of the possible values that my
function can take on and we can call
that the range
there are more formal ways to talk about
this and i there's a much more rigorous
discussion of this later on especially
in the linear algebra playlist but this
is all the different values i can take
on so if i take the if i take the number
two from our domain i input it into the
function we're getting mapped to the
number eight so let let me draw that out
so we're going from two
to
the number 8
right there and it's being done by the
function
the function is doing that mapping that
function is mapping us from 2
to 8. this right here that is equal to f
of two
same idea you start with three
three is being mapped
three is being mapped by the function to
ten
to ten it's creating an association the
function is mapping us from 3
to 10.
now this raises an interesting question
is there a way to get back from 8 to the
2 or is there a way to go back from the
10 to the 3 or is there some other
function is there some other function we
can call that the inverse of f that will
take us back
is there some other function
that will take us from 10 back to 3.
we'll call that the inverse of f and
we'll use that as a notation and it'll
take us back from 10 to 3. is there a
way to do that is that well that same
inverse of f will it take us back from
if we take if we apply 8 to it
will that take us back to 2 will the
inverse of f if we apply it to 8 will it
take us back to 2. now all of this seems
very
abstract and difficult what you'll find
is it's actually very easy to solve for
this inverse of f i think once we solve
for it'll make it clear what i'm talking
about that the function takes you from 2
to 8 the inverse will take us back from
8 to 2. so to think about that let's
just define let's just say y is equal to
f of x
so let's say y is equal to f of x so y
is equal to f of x is equal to 2x plus
4. so i could write just y is equal to
2x
plus 4. and this once again this is our
function it you give me an x it will
give me a y but we want to go the other
way around we want to give you a y and
get an x so all we have to do is solve
4x in terms of y so let's do that if we
subtract 4 from both sides of this
equation let me switch colors if we
switch if we subtract 4 from both sides
of this equation we get y minus 4 is
equal to 2x and then if we divide both
sides of this equation by 2
we get y
over 2
minus 2 right 4 divided by 2 is 2 is
equal to x so if we just want to write
it that way we can just swap the sides
we get x is equal to
one-half y same thing as y over 2
minus 2.
so what we have here is a function of y
that gives us an x which is exactly what
we wanted we want a function of these
values that map back to an x so we could
call this we could say that this is
equal to
this is equal to i'll do it in that same
color this is equal to
f inverse
as a function of y or let me just write
a little bit cleaner we could say f
inverse
as a function of y so we could have tan
or eight so now the range is now the
domain for f inverse f inverse as a
function of y is equal to
one half y
minus two so all we did is we started
with our original function y is equal to
two x plus four we solved for
over here we have we've solved for y in
terms of x then we just do a little bit
of algebra solve for x in terms of y and
we say that that is our f our inverse as
a function of y which is right over here
and then if we you know you could say
this is you can replace the y with an a
a b and x whatever you want to do so
then we can just we can just rename the
y as x so if you if you put an x into
this function you would get f inverse
of x is equal to one half
x
minus two so all you do you solve for x
and then you swap the y and the x if you
want to view it that way that's the
easiest way to think about it and one
thing i want to point out is what
happens when you graph the function and
the inverse so let me just do a little
quick and dirty graph right here
and then i'll do a bunch of examples of
actually solving for inverses but i
really just wanted to give you the firs
the general idea function takes you from
the domain of the range the inverse will
take you from that point back to the
original value if it exists
so if i were to graph these so let me
draw a little coordinate axis right here
draw a little bit of a coordinate axis
right there
this first function 2x plus 4
its y-intercept is going to be 1 2 3 4
just like that and then it will
its its slope will look like this it has
a slope of 2
so it will
look something like it's the graph will
look let me make it a little bit neater
than that it'll look something like that
that's what that function looks like
what does this function look like what
does the inverse function look like as a
function of x remember we solved for x
and then we swapped the x and the y
essentially we could say now that y
is equal to f inverse of x
so we have a a y intercept of negative 2
1 2
and now the slope is one half
so the slope is one half the slope looks
like this let me see if i can draw it
the slope looks or the line looks
something like that
and what's the relationship here i mean
you know these look kind of related it
looks like they're reflected about
something and it'll be a little bit more
clear what they're reflected about if we
draw the line y is equal to x so the
line y equals x looks like that i'll do
it as a dotted line
right the line y equals x
looks something like that that is the
line y is equal to x and you can see you
have the function and its inverse
they're reflected about the line y is
equal to x and hopefully that makes
sense here because over here on this
line let's take an easy example
our function when you take when you take
0 so f of 0 is equal to 4 our function
is mapping
0 to 4 right the inverse function
the inverse function if you take f
inverse of 4
f inverse of 4 is equal to 0 or the
inverse function is mapping us from 4 to
0 which is exactly what we expected the
function gives us takes us from the x to
the y world and then use we swap it we
we're swapping the x and the y when we
take the inverse and that's why it's
reflected around y equals x so this
example that i just showed you right
here function takes you from
to
4 we actually do that in the function
color
so the function takes you from 0
to 4 that's the function f of 0 is 4 you
see that right there so it goes from
zero to four and then the inverse takes
us back from four
to zero
so f inverse takes us back from four to
zero you saw that right there when you
evaluate four here one half times four
minus two is zero the next couple of
videos we'll do a bunch of examples so
you really understand how to solve these
and able to do the exercises on on our
on our application for this